No!
What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And today it's time for i-Pong
Let's go!
Come on!
No!
It's easy to go around the net
In this table set-up
No!
Sorry
It was a laugh and then "sorry"
Just a bit too slow
Miikka would have got it easily
Oh
Yes!
Those are pretty good backhands
No!
Now it's coming!
You did the same mistake as me!
No!
That's an interesting technique
Who else has a grip like this?
Come on!
Sorry!
Sorry
Sorry not sorry.
Of course it ends with an around the net
I quite like this set-up because you don't have to move so much in this.
Yeah, I saw that it was quite enjoyable for you
- unlike for me
But remember to subscribe
and watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!